(applaudissements)
- La voilà, elle est enfin
apparue, devant une foule
en liesse. Quatre jours que
les Britanniques la célèbrent
malgré son absence. Elle est
arrivée sur le fameux balcon
de Buckingham palace entourée
de sa garde rapprochée :
son fils le futur roi, et
le prince William, le deuxième
dans l'ordre de succession.
♪ ♪ ♪
Puis, le célèbre "God save
the Queen", suivi d'un feu
d'artifice aux couleurs
du Union Jack.
Dans un communiqué, elle
remercie les Britanniques.
"Il n'y a pas de précédent
pour célébrer 70 ans de règne
écrit-elle. Je n'ai pu
participer aux fes
mais mon coeur était avec
vous tous et je continuerai
à vous servir de mon mieux."
- C'est le carrosse doré,
vieux de 260 ans qui a ouvert
la parade. Le même que la jeune
Elizabeth II a pris lors de
son couronnement, il y a 70 ans.
Pendant deux heures,
un défilé d'abord militaire,
puis artistique, reflétant
les différentes périodes
de l'histoire de la Grande
Bretagne. Aux premières loges,
le prince Charles et sa femme
Camilla entourés du Prince
William et de sa famille.
Un défilé haut en couleurs
représentant chaque décennie.
Une journée rythmée par
des piques-niques à travers
tout le pays. À Windsor, on a
aligné 488 tables sur l'alléemeu
des festivités a été le concertt
la reine avec le célèbre
ourson Paddington qui a donné
la première note. Ce jubilé
a révélé une reine frêle qui
est à la fin de son règne et
qui prépare sa succession.
Elle souhaite que l'unité autour
de la couronne se poursuive
pendant des années.
Avec ou sans elle...
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Lon